一个被OpenAI开除的
24岁年轻人
没有任何基金管理经验
写了一篇长文
就募到了15亿美元
持仓全是AI核心股
与此同时
95岁的巴菲特
手握近4000亿美金现金
什么都不买
在等崩盘
这两个人
代表了当下投资界最典型的分歧
这个年轻人叫
Leopold Aschenbrenner
他创立的对冲基金
叫Situational Awareness
（态势感知）
美股股权敞口
已经做到了55亿美金
2015年上半年扣费之后
回报率高达47%
远超同期标普500的6%
这个人是什么来头呢
19岁从哥伦比亚大学毕业
加入了OpenAI的超级对齐团队
2024年4月
据说因为泄露信息被开除了
被开除之后
他干了一件让所有人意外的事
写了一篇165页的长文
核心观点很炸裂
2027年AGI就会到来
美国应该以曼哈顿计划级别
来搞AI基建
这篇文章
在硅谷投资圈、科技圈
乃至白宫都传疯了
然后他直接拿文章标题
当基金名字
开始募资
他的投资逻辑跟巴菲特完全不同
巴菲特的继任者阿贝尔说
"我们不会为了AI而AI
只有看到真实价值才出手"
而Leopold恰恰就是在赌
AI会彻底改变一切
别人追英伟达
追大模型公司的时候
他直接盯到了
当下AI正在遭遇的物理瓶颈
缺电 他就买Bloom Energy
给数据中心做
燃料电池的这家公司
缺带宽
他就买做光模块的Lumentum
缺算力
他就买CoreWeave
和Core Scientific
缺存储 他就买SanDisk
从建仓到现在涨了7倍多
最经典的一笔
是英特尔
2025年年初
所有人都觉得英特尔完了
他反手买了4.59亿美金的
看涨期权
后来英伟达投资
英特尔代工的消息一出来
英特尔暴涨
据说他一天赚10亿美元
你再看他最新的
2025年第四季度的持仓
前几大重仓
最近全部大涨
这两种投资哲学的对比
放在此时此刻特别有意思
刚刚结束的
伯克希尔股东大会上
巴菲特在场外专访里直言
现在不是理想的投资环境
伯克希尔的操作
也确实偏向保守
现在的仓位只有42% 现金58%
已经连续三年多净卖出股票
十大持仓全是
这些传统消费
和金融公司为主
整个AI概念几乎没碰
那么代价是什么呢
伯克希尔今年股价跌了6%
同期标普涨了6%
纳指涨了7%
相对跑输超过10个点
但是巴菲特完全不在乎
手握现金等崩盘
Leopold的逻辑完全反过来
他All in AI基础设施
用看涨期权去加杠杆
现在几乎是纯多头进攻姿态
根据外界的估算
他的隐含杠杆率
可能高达14倍
当然Leopold的故事
还远没有结束
对冲基金调仓极快
高杠杆策略
也意味着高风险
到底是‘常识’能穿越周期
还是"愿景"能重塑逻辑呢
这还犹未可知
关注硅谷101
不要错过全球科技与
商业的最新动态